dans cette rue d'isium les maisons
tiennent péniblement debout à l'entrée
de celle-ci un panneau indique foyer
avec trois petits enfants la jeune
famille que nous rencontrons tente de
survivre au milieu des horreurs de la
guerre la maison de Margarita a été
touchée à trois reprises d'abord par
l'explosion d'un char puis par des tirs
d'artillerie
et enfin dit-elle par une bombe à
fragmentation que son fils Nikita âgé de
10 ans a vu tomber du ciel
j'ai ramassé les pierres pour jouer
quand j'ai entendu un sifflement dans le
ciel et j'ai crié quelque chose tombe
qui pourront à la cave c'était effrayant
[Musique]
c'est le dernier à être descendu dans
l'abri pendant qu'il courait des éclats
d'obus frappaient déjà les fenêtres dieu
merci Nikita a entendu sinon les enfants
auraient été réduits en miettes parce
que là où il jouait tout a été touché
en ce mois d'octobre le jardin est
redevenu un terrain de jeu paisible
il n'y a plus d'explosion maintenant
nous n'avons plus besoin de courir à la
maison pour nous cacher
la famille a survécu plus de 5 mois sous
l'Occupation dans cette ville longtemps
concentrée sur la ligne de front
Margarita nous décrit comment elle
hurlait aux soldat russe de lui donner
des provisions
à manger les enfants enfin j'ai trois
enfants peu de temps après ils sont
venus nous apporter du ragoût et des
pâtes des aliments inadaptés pour un
nourrisson son bébé Sofiane avait que
trois mois lorsque la Russie a lancé son
invasion
c'est ça qui nous a sauvé même quand les
avions volaient au-dessus de nos têtes
j'essayais de rester calme parce que je
savais que si je stressais trop mon lait
allait se tarir et j'avais peur de ne
plus pouvoir le nourrir
à quelques rues une autre famille n'a
pas pu fuir pendant l'Occupation
s'éloigner des ruines maintenant que les
combats ont cessé se fera à contre-cœur
pour la maman de ses deux garçons
nos écoles et nos jardins d'enfants sont
complètement détruits et il n'y a pas de
soin médicaux approprié je veux vivre
pas seulement survivre
elle aussi à un bébé Catalina né en mai
en plein milieu de la guerre
doux et d'électricité
mais les médecins m'ont aidé à accoucher
naturellement et tout s'est bien passé
dieu merci
[Musique]
une fois ils ont tambouriné à la porte
de manière très agressive et nous ont
demandé qu'est-ce que vous faites ici
vous êtes au courant que c'est la guerre
dehors et mon mari a répondu vous voulez
qu'on aille où exactement
elle rêve aujourd'hui de se réfugier en
Allemagne pour offrir un répit à ses
enfants le temps qu'il grandisse loin de
cette guerre pour elle l'espère pouvoir
mieux revenir ensuite